[MUSIC PLAYING]
ERIC SCHMIDT: Good morning.
Welcome to day
three of Next 2018.
My name is Eric Schmidt.
I'm a developer advocate in
the Google Cloud Platform team.
You can reach me on
Twitter @notthateric.
If you were expecting the other
Eric Schmidt, I apologize.
Hopefully, you're
in the right room.
This session is architecting
live NCAA predictions
from Archives to Insight.
You can also reach
me at CLOUDE--
Cloud with an E--
at google.com if you want to
have a private conversation
outside of Twitter.
How many of you have
ever built a house?
Or remodeled a house?
Or know a friend who's remodeled
a house or built a house?
This is a picture of a house I
remodeled a little while ago.
And I was trying to figure
how to start the talk
and I realized that
this is a great way
to set the context for
what this talk is about.
Building a house is really
hard and without plans
and without a lot
of communication,
a lot of different
tools, and collaboration,
you'll more than likely fail.
Fortunately, through a
lot of trial and error--
I'll show you a
picture maybe later
about what this ended up looking
like-- but keep this in mind.
As you're building
something, it's
important to have a foundation.
It's important to have a plan.
And a lot of patience.
This is one of my plans.
What's this talk about?
This talk is about three things.
It's about NCAA and basketball.
It's about the Google Cloud.
And it's about
predictive workflow,
specifically for live
TV advertisements.
How many people are
into basketball?
How many people are into Cloud?
Predictions?
Wow, we have a pretty
good event here.
This is great, awesome.
I'm going to walk between
these three concepts,
jumping back and forth.
It'd be awesome to do
this talk linearly,
but it would also be impossible.
And most of what I'm
going to share with you
are things that
happened to myself
and several other--
several meaning
15 to 20-- people in
real-time, in real life.
And I'm going to
share with you some
of the best practices that
we learned and applied along
the way.
Real quickly, since this
talk is about the NCAA--
if you don't know
who the NCAA is,
it's important to understand.
So the NCAA is the governing
body for collegiate sports.
And at the end of the
day, their mission
is to help be an integral part
of higher education for college
student athletes.
And to prove an environment for
them that's safe, productive,
and help build some of the
most amazing championships
on the planet.
How did we get here?
How did this talk happen?
How did these ads happen?
Back in December of
2017, Google Cloud
became the official Cloud
provider for the NCAA.
The NCAA has a lot
of typical challenges
or has a lot of challenges
of a typical enterprise.
Although, people may not think
of the NCAA as an enterprise.
But the NCAA manages hundreds
and hundreds of schools
times the number of sports--
thousands of sports.
It's just not about basketball.
You have football,
baseball, soccer, et cetera.
They have decades and decades
of competition information
and student athlete information.
This partnership was grounded
in helping the NCAA build
the future of their
analytics platform
to help them understand in more
detail, potentially, what's
happening with some
of their sports
and some of the
competitions in areas
that they may have
had a blind spot to
or they wanted to get
more insight in to.
The campaign was, Know
What Your Data Knows.
So they have lots of
data, but there were areas
that we wanted to dig deeper.
One of those was supporting
the development of a refined
championship selection process.
So looking at, how
are teams selected
to be in some of the
championships that they manage?
So the partnership started
in December, kind of based
on these three ideas.
How many of you are
fans of March Madness?
Now for some of you that
didn't understand or know
who the NCAA was, March Madness
is a championship tournament
that happens every year.
Guess what month it starts in?
March.
There are 351 NCAA
Division I schools
that compete for a
spot to participate
and this 64-team tournament.
There's a women's tournament
and a men's tournament.
This talk is primarily focused
on the men's tournament.
So you have 351 teams.
They all are vying to get into
a spot into this tournament.
The NCAA oversees the
selection process--
so which teams get in--
and then, how they're
seeded into the tournament.
That process is
very data driven.
Primarily, using
historical game data
to make decisions
about what teams
deserve the right to
play in the tournament.
Google Cloud is part
of this fantastic
madness around March Madness.
We decided that we were going
to build six live television
ads to run during
the Final Four games.
Anyone want to guess how many
games are in the Final Four?
Three.
So we ran two ads--
one for each game.
And this is the journey
that we took to build out
these live television ads.
Let's take a trip.
How many have you been to
Austin, Texas-- not Austin.
How many of you have
been to the Alamodome?
April 2, 2018, there was a
truck sitting right about here.
And the National
Championship Game
was going on inside
of this building.
This is me, right there.
I'm only self-identifiable
by my gray hair.
So we're watching the game and
as soon as the clock hit zero,
zero at halftime,
we built an ad that
didn't exist prior to the clock
going to 0, 0 from scratch
and we ran it live on
air, predicting what would
happen in the second half.
So immerse yourself in
being in this truck.
This truck is roughly, 10 by 12.
It's super hot.
It's filled with about 13 people
watching a game that about say,
80-100 million
people are watching--
I don't know how many
people watch the game,
a lot of people--
and we have to go run an ad.
By the way, this
guy right here is
was one of my main
partners on this project
and he doesn't look
too happy right now.
Let's watch an ad.
What did we build?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
So that ad ran,
roughly four minutes
into the beginning of the game.
Turns out, possessions are
pretty important in basketball
because you can't score if
you don't have the ball.
Turns out, pace is super
important in basketball
because if you're behind,
you need the ball in order
to score.
So 130 possessions is that good?
Is that bad?
Is that a lot?
We'll find out, but
that was our estimate,
that was our prediction.
So how did we go from
building that ad,
running that ad,
sitting in that truck--
how did we get there?
This is the overall architecture
that we ended up building.
So we started building this
late November, early December
right around the start of this
relationship with the NCAA.
Starting on the left hand
side, we have raw data.
And then finishing on the right
side, we have a television ad.
Voila, we're done.
We're out.
No, there was several pieces
that we had to put together
and we're going to walk
through this left to right.
Now if you're not
into product logos
and you think more in terms
of workflow and tasks,
this is a different way
to look at this talk.
So we're going to talk about
orchestration and subject
matter expertise, business
requirements, et cetera.
You're going to see several--
probably, 15-- of
these green slides.
These are best practices.
If you take nothing
away from this talk,
try to remember what's
on these green slides.
I showed you the architecture.
Step 1.
If you're going to go
build something like this,
form a team of discrete
subject matter experts.
People who know what they
know really, really well.
And also, know what
they don't know.
Our team effort
looked like this.
We had basically,
two camps of folks--
I'll call them,
the techie people
and the non-techie people.
So the left column, we had a
tech partner lead-- someone
who worked closely with the NCAA
and other technology groups.
We had a gentleman on the
team who is a deep, deep NCAA
basketball expert.
We had folks that just
did data engineering.
Some folks that just did
software engineering.
Some people were quants.
Other people were just focused
on data science and machine
learning engineering.
Then on the business side, we
had a business partner lead--
again, folks who were working
with the NCAA, working
with Turner, et cetera.
People writing copy.
Making sure that what we
were doing was on brand.
That the ad process
was working right.
PR folks, legal folks.
And ultimately, some
editors and one of them
is in the audience today.
So you have this collection
of people and the reason
why I point this out is I've
worked on probably, a hundred
of these projects.
And I always ask, who's
your data engineer?
And the data science guy or
girl says, we don't have one.
That's kind of me, I just
I just do that on the side.
How much time are
you then spending
doing data engineering versus
actually doing data science
work?
And you start getting
into this challenge of not
being able to
focus on the things
that you're really,
really good at.
Now that's not to say
that it's OK to crossover,
but if you're trying to
do something really big,
make sure that you're
staffed appropriately
around the disciplines that you
need in order to be successful.
And as you'll see,
there's no way
that a single machine
learning engineer sitting
in one of our data
centers by themselves
could pull something like
this off without a ton
of other support.
Next one-- and I promise you,
you'll see some code here soon.
The next one is write down
business requirements.
Scope as soon as possible.
And communicate with precision.
So that group of
technologists talking
to a group of business folks--
in the beginning,
it was hard for us
to communicate because we
weren't writing down things.
We're like, yeah, we're
going to build these ads.
What do you mean we're
going to build ads?
How many do we need to build?
When do they run?
How fast do they
need to get done?
Et cetera.
And then, iteration is key.
So decisions that we make today
or a decision that we say,
made today, three days
from now more than likely
we're going to tweak
that based on new inputs
both from the technology side,
as well as the business side.
So how do we get to
business requirements?
These were words
that I distinctly
remember in meetings.
You can guess which ones maybe
come from the business side
versus the technology side.
So people say hey, we want
these ads to be delightful.
Like, cool.
What does that mean?
And then the folks in
the technology side
is like, how precise
do we have to be?
And then the legal guys will
be like, don't be too right,
but don't be too wrong.
As one of the leads on this
project, I was always saying,
is this even feasible?
Can we pull this off?
So we wrote a bunch
of documents and we
started to get very crisp
and clear about what
a lot of these words meant.
From there, we started to
narrow down scope as a means
to start building a
predictive workflow.
So we had some team rules.
So first and foremost,
this has to be on brand.
So it had to feel like Google.
It also had to
feel like the NCAA.
It had to be contextual.
It had to be about basketball.
It had to be about the
game that was happening.
Had to have mass appeal.
I wanted to run ads that
were just around dunks,
but turns out, not
everyone likes dunks.
And then we had this idea
of Goldilocks outcome
so it couldn't be too hot and
it also couldn't be too cold.
Then we had a bunch
of other things,
like don't be to basketball-y.
Needs to feel delightful.
And then-- by the way--
all this system that we were
building on the workflow side
needed to be executed
in under two minutes.
So everything else aside,
soon as that clock hits zero,
we have two minutes
to basically,
hand off information
to our creative team
to go build an ad.
Then, we finally got to this.
Wrote this down,
printed it on my wall,
and then didn't sleep
for four months, which
was build X number of
real-time predictions to power
the development of
six television ads.
Each of these have to
run in under 10 minutes,
from start to finish for
them to getting traffic.
With Goldilocks accuracy,
while being prepared
for hundreds of game scenarios.
How many of you
knew who was going
to play in the Final Four
games or Championship games
whenever the tournament started?
Cool.
Lot of honest people
in this audience.
So how did we get there?
Step 1, collect data.
Step 3, adds-- that's a
joke from "South Park,"
probably too old
So we're going to
work left the right.
As we were building
out this new analytics
workflow for the NCAA,
we got very close,
intimate with the
data that they had.
And we're talking about
decades and decades
worth of competition data.
At the same time, we also
worked with a data provider
called Sport Radar.
They are a provider of
real-time sport information
and they also support the NCAA,
as well as Turner Broadcasting.
And the reason we
worked with them
is they have real-time
information about what's
happening on the court versus
the majority of the NCAA data
is all historical in nature.
So step 1, collect data.
How many of you love XML?
I wrote one of the
first XML parsers
at Microsoft about 15 years ago.
I thought it was the
best thing on the planet.
It turns out that there are
other encoding formats that
are a little bit better.
But historically, we had to
deal with tens of thousands
of these files that
represented what
happened in these NCAA games.
Some of them are
15,000-20,000 lines long.
How many of you loved JSON?
Slightly more than
the response from XML.
Still, fun format, a little
bit easier to deal with.
The challenge here would be--
in both cases-- what happens
if you have missing data?
What happens if you
have malformed data?
Tens of thousands of
these files, as well,
for us to just
understand historically
what happened with all the
games inside of NCAA Division I
basketball.
So what did we do?
We went and started
to build a process
to look at the NCAA's data,
as well as Sport Radar data.
It just wasn't about games.
We had to look at schedules.
We had to look at rosters.
We had to look at reference
data, like locations, box
scores, play-by-plays.
Ultimately, we were sitting
on around 100,000 files,
all different types of schema.
By the way, the women's
game has different rules,
different timing
than the men's game.
So we were like, oh great.
And then we had to build
two different systems.
We had different primary
keys across this data.
Different ways to pull it.
So ultimately, we had to build
a workflow around our data
engineering process.
So next best practice--
treat data engineering
as a first-class citizen
in your overall workflow.
I see this get kicked
to the side a lot,
like, yeah, there's some folks
working on that over there.
They'll handle all the
ingestion and transformation.
And also, ingestion is a
function of data engineering,
so just even acquiring
the data can be
an extremely difficult problem.
Next one-- and this is what
you'll see what we built--
is as you start building
out your ingestion
and transformation workflow,
build something that
is repeatable and automatable.
Just because you can go
download a couple of files using
some HTTP-JSON hacked
together implementation,
doesn't mean you can do this
repeatedly over and over
and over again, potentially
thousands of times at scale.
We used Apache Beam--
and then, you'll see
here in a minute--
Cloud Dataflow to drive the
majority of our ingestion
and transformation process.
This stuff can be a little
boring because most people just
want to get to predictions.
But as you'll see,
this is probably
one of the most critical
sections in building out
your workflow is being
able to ingest and then
transform that data into
something that's actionable.
So we leveraged Apache Beam.
And then, wrote a series of ETL
pipelines that said, go out,
pull X to Y space from the
NCAA for certain schema types.
Do some transformation
on that JSON and/or XML.
And then, ultimately
load it into BigQuery.
The third point about
avoid inline mapping--
you'll see this in
some of the code.
I've noticed
sometimes people say,
well, I know that
this game ID over
here or this value over
here maps just directly
to this column over here.
So all I'm going to do
is just read from here
and write to there.
Try to avoid inline mapping
whenever you're doing this
because ultimately, something's
going to change in your system
either on the database
side or on the input side.
So come up with some type
of common type system
that you map to.
And Apache Beam provides an
excellent environment for you
to create a type
system, whether you're
in Java, Python, et cetera.
We were also writing this
data to a Cloud Storage
to Spanner and to
some other syncs
because we needed the
ability to interact
with this data in different
types of environments.
So that's another benefit
of us using Apache Beam,
in this case, is we
read from one source,
but then, we're writing
to multiple syncs.
So let's go ahead and
ingest all of 2016.
Here's the code-- some
of the code that I wrote,
the pipeline code.
I'll make this a little bigger.
It's pretty self-explanatory.
So in Apache Beam, I'm going
to go write a transform that
knows how to go read from
a particular source--
in this case, all the
box score summaries.
And then I have a
summary parser that
knows how to take that JSON or
XML, convert it to a Java type,
and then I have a writer.
And in this case,
my summary writer
ends up splitting a single input
into three different tables.
So I have a summary
about the games.
I have a summary about the
players in those games.
And I have a summary about
the scoring for those games.
And the beauty of this is, is
I can kind of rip and replace
one of my outputs.
I can push it someplace else.
I can add another
output if I need it.
And after I stitch all of
my transforms together,
I go ahead and hit Run.
I could run this locally, but
I would blow up my machine
because we have tens of
thousands of files here.
But I could do that, test
on a few, but let's go ahead
and run this in the Cloud.
So hit Run.
And the command line is going
to package up all my Apache Beam
code, call out to Cloud
Dataflow, kick off a job
and start reading all my files.
For the sake of
time, we can go look
at what this looks
like in the Console.
So if I go ahead
and look at this,
here is a view of
one of those jobs.
So I have the first
step was basically,
loading my summaries.
Then I have my parser.
Then I have my writer.
We ran these jobs
thousands and thousands
and thousands of times.
And that's the beauty of
building A, a type system
and then leveraging something
like Apache Beam or another ETL
framework in order to
get this work done.
Great.
So in just 2016, a lot of our
focus was around the 15 years
prior to this recent
March Madness.
We were constantly going
back and pulling in 15 years,
15 years, 15 years.
Now that we have
some data, let's
start doing some
exploratory analysis.
Next best practice.
This one I stuck to pretty hard.
If the data wasn't in
BigQuery, it didn't happen.
We had lots of conversations
with folks on the team like,
I found this super data or this
feature and it's really great.
And I'm like, where is it?
Well, it's on my laptop,
or it's in this CSV file,
or I have it in a spreadsheet.
It's over on GCS.
I'm like, I don't care.
If it's not in BigQuery,
it didn't happen.
So consequently, folks
were looking at, well,
how do I get data into BigQuery?
I don't want to go write
a big Apache Beam job.
Fortunately, BigQuery has a
nice UI that I can just go
and say go ahead and import
CSV, import Avro, et cetera,
and get data into BigQuery.
Let's look at some data in
BigQuery that we loaded up.
This is probably, the
simplest run to look at.
This is looking at the
total count of games
by year for men's
Division I basketball.
I ran this one a lot just as a
verification, like smoke test.
Like yeah, there's roughly,
5,791 games in a year.
Doesn't really tell you
much, but that's a good audit
process.
And I had all types of different
data outputs from my Apache
Beam jobs or those one-off
jobs in our BigQuery project.
The query that I
just showed you is--
I don't know-- not very helpful.
So I'm going to show you another
query which was something
that, as a team,
we quickly realized
was a very valuable thing to
do, which is as we found things
that were interesting,
we rented them as views
and then started sharing them.
So instead of just
having some static SQL
sitting around in source
control somewhere,
it was like, hey, I have a view.
It has something
that's interesting.
I'll go ahead and share it.
And a lot of these
views, their goal
were to do things
like grouping by team,
grouping by conference.
Doing time series quantization.
Things that we
had to do in order
to basically, aggregate data
into something meaningful.
So if I go here, this query--
this is one of the
original ones we wrote.
We were interested
to see, is there
a difference amongst
conferences-- there's
32 conferences in
Division I basketball--
is there a difference among
conferences in their home court
advantage?
Do you think that there's a
difference among conferences
in home court advantage?
Maybe, I don't know.
So I write this query.
It's interesting, it
shows me some data,
but it's kind of hard to
see what this really means.
So you kind of have a
hunch that, yeah, there's
probably a difference
in home court advantage.
One of the nice features
inside of BigQuery
is I can click on the
outputs of my query
and say, visualize
inside of Data Studio.
And in this case, I want
to look at the home point
advantage, which was
the output of my query.
And I can quickly
visualize that yes, there
is a difference between
PAC-12 playing at home.
They're favored by about four
and a half points on average
versus the Ivy League
or the Big South or MAC.
So I haven't built
any predictions yet,
but I'm starting to kind of
gain some insight on what
things could be
skillful in terms
of building out predictions.
Say if you have a PAC-12
team playing a Colonial
team during March Madness.
Keep in mind,
though, that they're
playing on neutral courts so we
have another problem to solve,
but this is an amazing way
to start exploring data.
By the way, Data
Studio's free and all
of the visualizations that
you build inside of it
are easily shareable.
If you've played with Google
Docs, go ahead and click Share,
you'll have access to your data.
Don't want to do that.
So we can explore
data in BigQuery.
We built views to
satisfy common use cases.
We also spent some time
looking at our audit logs
and just talking to folks, like
hey, what are you building?
What are you writing?
And they're like, I
wrote this cool query.
Great, let's go ahead
and materialize that
as a viewer as a table so you
stop running the query over
and over again and you get
a little bit more efficient.
The next thing that we did
was look at some visualization
techniques outside of
BigQuery and Data Studio,
which is using Cloud Datalab.
So Cloud Datalab is a
hostable implementation
of IPython Notebook.
You can run it locally
in a docker container.
You could also run
it on the Cloud.
Go ahead and just use
our gcloud commands
to go create a Datalab instance.
And I have a fully
fleshed out IPython
development environment that is
optimized for the Google Cloud.
And once you're there, you
can do something like this.
I'm in my IPython Notebook--
make this a little bigger--
and I take my BigQuery
that I wrote--
this is for a different
type of analysis--
move it over into Datalab.
I execute that query.
It's a fairly big query.
I pump it into a data frame
and do some visualization.
So this visualization
was focused
on understanding how players
on teams on an individual basis
can contribute to the three
points that a team is scoring.
So in this case,
Kentucky on average
has three players
that contribute
the majority of their
three-point production
versus Davidson, who has
five different folks who
are contributing to the
three-point production.
So you could look
at this and start
to make some inferences, like
three guys versus five guys who
are able to produce
three-pointers,
who has the advantage?
So I can visualize
in Data Studio,
sitting on top of BigQuery.
I can visualize
inside of Datalab
sitting on top of a BigQuery.
By the way, if you go out
to medium.com and look
for analyzing NCAA college
basketball with GCP,
we have about 30 articles
that reinforces some of the--
we'll call them,
classic visualizations
and feature ideas that
we were coming up with.
So the best practice here,
if you think something
is interesting, visualize it.
If you don't know if something
If you find something that
you thought was interesting
and it turns out not to be
interesting, visualize it
and share it with the team.
So now we're going to go
from exploratory analysis
to looking at some features.
Some things to keep in mind,
all 351 teams in Division I
basketball are not equal in
strength and performance.
If that was the case, man, this
would be a really, really hard
tournament to pick the teams.
But in our case, we
wouldn't necessarily
know who all the Final Four
teams were until a week out,
so as we were thinking
about features
and what type of
models we would build,
we had a plan for a very,
very broad set of use cases.
From there, as we started
to drive into the features
that we were going to use,
then we had to stop and say,
what are we predicting on?
We still haven't gotten there.
So the conversations between
the tech folks and the business
folks, we came down to
these 28 predictions.
So we had predictions
focused on single team.
And we had predictions
focused on combined stats
between teams.
And then we also had these
predictions around game state.
We focused on close and
late and down to the wire.
In essence, we had to go
build 28 predictions for each
of these games across
these categories.
So this is the number
of predictions.
And then looking into those
prediction categories,
we started looking at
what's interesting?
What makes three-point
attempts interesting?
Or possessions interesting?
So before you saw
up there, it was
said 130 was the estimate for
the number of possessions.
So on this slide, we
looked at the distribution
of all of these stats
across 2017 men's Division I
basketball.
And it turns out,
130 possessions
would be roughly, around
the 50th percentile--
down in the bottom.
Now keep in mind, this
is across all teams.
We don't necessarily
know who's going
to play in the Championship
Game or Final Four,
but this gives you
some indication about,
what is interesting?
Where would those
numbers fall if you
were looking at all teams?
So the next thing
to do was we knew
which prediction categories
we wanted to go after.
We knew potentially,
what was interesting.
Then we had to figure out, what
type of modeling techniques
are we going to use here?
Are we going to use
regression techniques?
classification techniques?
So if you're new to this,
this is a real quick slide.
The idea of regression
is I'm going
to take some input
variables and then, output
some continuous variable.
And the whole idea is I'm
trying to build a function
to do this--
the magic of machine learning.
So my input variables would
be all these different stats
and the output variable
would be how many possessions
are going to be in this game.
How many three-point attempts
From a classification
perspective,
again, n number of
variables and then,
output some discrete variable.
So is this game going
to be close and late?
Yes or no?
So you have some type of
binary classification.
The question here is, what is X?
What features should you
use to drive these models?
This is the hardest part.
This is like saying--
I had some funny things to say--
it's like, where the
babies come from?
We kind of know where
babies come from,
but the process, there's
all different types
of things that happen.
And how do you stitch
all of these things
together in order to create some
type of successful function?
And this is the whole process of
doing your feature exploration
and feature engineering.
So going back to our data,
we started talking to folks
and say, we have data about
conference, and seasons,
and games, and players,
and segments, et cetera.
Oh, by the way, we're
not using one tool.
We're using Tableau and
Jupiter and RStudio and Colab,
et cetera.
But everyone was able to
rally around using BigQuery
as the center of
truth for the data.
You want to use RStudio?
Awesome, rock.
Easy connectivity to BigQuery.
You're in Colab?
Go for it.
Everyone was looking
at the same data.
From here, we can then look at
what features could potentially
be skillful.
This was a model that we wrote.
It was a classification
feature to see
if a game would fall into
higher than the 75th percentile
for a particular stat.
I think in this case, it
was three-point attempts.
So we would start with hundreds
and hundreds of features
and using different
techniques, we
could start to look at which
features were most skillful.
Which ones were going to give
signal to drive a prediction.
Interestingly enough,
if you're looking
at three-point attempts, one
of the most skillful features
is the average of three-point
attempts by a team
in their last seven games.
That's an easy one, but if
you only had one feature,
your model may not
be very powerful.
So we go searching
for more features
and looking at things like--
let me scroll down here
and find another one that's
interesting--
free throw attempts in
[? an average ?] seven games.
You can see there's a
little bit of distribution
between these two.
So there are
different techniques
to go through your
feature selection process.
The point here is that whatever
tool that you're choosing
has access to the same data.
And as we were doing our work--
one of the guys in the
audience was on the team--
we would be saying,
in my process,
I see that this feature
is really skillful.
Great, go ahead and
put it back into a view
so then everyone can use it.
So best practice.
So use views to help
build out your features
that you're selecting.
Version them-- this
was another thing
that people were
like, a week ago I
had a feature that seemed to
be pretty skillful, but now
where did that thing go?
So use views and
just version them.
Another best practice,
use SQL as much
as possible to build the
aggregations for your features.
I had lots of conversations
with people and they would say,
I wrote this wicked pandas code
in IPython that extracts data.
It does a bunch of
aggregation and loops
and blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I have awesome features.
I'm like, great.
Could I have that?
And then they send the code,
check it in, and I run it.
I'm like, hey, this takes
an hour and a half to run.
And 95% of that could
have been done in SQL,
could we take that process
and put it into SQL
so that I can just leverage
BigQuery to push all that down
and run it in 12 seconds?
Now granted, there are some
cases where you can't do that,
but if you're not
trying to do it,
then you won't
necessarily know at what
point do you need to jump out
of some hand-crafted environment
and leverage SQL.
Other best practice--
all engineering artifacts
should live in source control.
Persistent disks
attached to VMs does not
qualify as source control.
Your laptop that
you think is secure
does not satisfy
as source control.
Build a system, get whatever
workflow you want to use,
make sure you're
checking everything.
So it's just not about code.
It's about SQL.
It's about your notebooks.
It's about your ideas.
So we talked about
some feature analysis.
Now let's get into modeling
and make some predictions.
So we use five different
tools to build out our models.
And we use BigQuery ML--
which was announced yesterday--
and it was a lifesaver
on this project.
We used Scikit-learn heavily.
We used XGBoost.
We used Keras and a
little bit of TensorFlow.
Again, the whole idea was--
whether we were building
a regression model or a
classification model--
we were using these
tools because these
are the tools that were helping
us build the best performance.
Not necessarily because it
was the tool that we liked.
So you'll see this in a minute--
choose the tool that works, not
the tool that you like to use.
And I'm going to jump over to--
the first one that
I'm going to show you
is our close and late model.
How many of you
would like to know
if a game was going to end close
and late at halftime so you
knew whether you should
just leave or stay at home?
So we built this
close and late model
and the person that built
it did all the right things.
They wrote down the
business requirements.
They were very, very
precise about what
this definition
of close and late
meant versus down
to the wire meant.
There's all the SQL that were
driving the feature inputs.
And talked about what types
of features that matter.
And then, ultimately, we
built some visualization
to show if this model
would trigger or not.
So our minimum threshold
for running an ad
around a prediction
was at minimum,
it had to be 65% confident.
So 65% probability that
this was going to happen.
Otherwise, we
wouldn't move forward.
So at halftime, the Villanova
score was 37, Michigan 28.
So Villanova was up by nine.
And if you look at this
graphic, Villanova's down here.
Here's Villanova whenever
they're up by 10.
We weren't even close to hitting
65% probability on this, which
was awesome because we knew that
this was a decision we were not
going to make.
We would not run this ad.
So this was close and late.
And the sad part is that
none of the Final Four games
ended up close and late.
And we did a ton of work
and never ran the ad.
D'oh!
But it was a lot of fun.
Another modeling technique
that we used was BigQuery ML.
So now we're back
into BigQuery, so I
took all those steps
of like feature
engineering, visualization,
et cetera, et cetera.
Now with BigQuery ML,
I have the ability
to build a model straight
in line and here's the code.
Basically, you say
create a replace model,
which is functionally just a
view inside of your data set.
I go ahead and
select the features
that I want to use so I
go ahead and selection
this really, really, really
wide view of features.
Go ahead [? and train. ?]
In this case, I wanted to
build a linear regression model
and it will output a model
for me then, to score.
So I've already
built this model.
I'll go ahead and flip
to the other view, which
is now I want to predict.
And I say, I need to
select from the game
that I want to look at.
So in this case, it was
the Championship Game.
I'm going to go ahead and
pull in all the stats, up
through the first half
and then run the query.
Check that.
This was all the stats
prior right up to the game.
So we were trying to predict
on total three-point attempts.
So our estimate for
that game was 50%--
sorry, the estimate was 49.85%
and the actual value was 50%.
So we had 28 different versions
of these models predicting
on all different stats
and we would run them
in real-time for us
to then, build out
a decision tree for which
ad we would run on TV.
So we've gotten all the
way through this process
and we're sitting in
the truck and we're
ready to make a decision.
How did we do it?
By the way, I can't underscore
the amount of pressure
that we were feeling because
we had to deliver an ad.
And that's kind of fun.
So what did we do?
We had automation for
serving each path.
So we had automation for
people using BigQuery.
We had automation for people
that were using TensorFlow.
And in some cases, some of
our automation was manual.
We had a person whose
job it was, hey,
I'm running this model.
This is how the thing works.
Here's the data
inputs that I need.
But the outputs of
all the automation
drove everything
into Google Sheets.
It's a lo-fi way, low-tech
to do it and it turns out,
it worked really, really well
because we could easily share
all this data with everyone.
We had to do nothing
to build it out other
than write some script and our
automation that says, right
now, here's the state
of all the predictions
that we want to make.
Pick the one that
feels the best.
And at halftime, this is
what we ended up looking at,
which was we ended up picking
three-points attempt combined
at the second half.
And with that data, we then
moved over to another system.
So part of this process
for this overall workflow,
are the ad agency and creative
agency that we worked with--
Eleven, here in San Francisco--
built out an
encoding system that
ran on the Cloud that
could take inputs
and then encode a live
ad in around 30 seconds.
So this was the
workflow that we used.
So we took the output
of our predictions
put them into the
encoding environment
and then, boom, outputs an ad.
What I don't show
you here is we had
a war room of around 100
different scenarios that
could possibly be happening.
It just wasn't around
three-point attempts.
It was three-point attempts
and the underdog was winning.
Or possessions and the
favorite team is up by 50.
We had all these
different scenarios
that we had to come up with
because the visualization
that you ultimately see
in the ad had to match
the context of the game.
Just because I could
give you a prediction
doesn't necessarily mean
it would resonate well,
unless the visuals met
the context of the game.
So with that, then we
had that encoded ad
and we trafficked it.
And that was a super fun process
because we were literally
on the phone with the
folks at Turner and CBS--
their ad trafficking people--
and said, yeah, we got your ad.
It's going to run.
And we sat there and
about two minutes later,
that ad was on
national television.
Eight minutes prior, nine
minutes prior, the ad
didn't exist.
The prediction didn't exist.
I remember, we have this
verification process
to understand what happened
when and why and I think in one
of the ads, there was a cat--
I think-- on the
back of a turtle--
is that right?
Yeah, there was a cat
on a back of a turtle
and you hear our auditor
talking to their auditor.
And the lady says,
yes, I can confirm
that there is a cat on
the back of the turtle.
And then they hang up the
phone and then the ad runs.
So another best practice
was we implemented a process
to audit the chain of command
regarding decision making.
So as those predictions
came out of the system,
we were looking at them.
We had a whole process to
figure out, this is good.
This is bad.
This reaches threshold,
this doesn't, et cetera.
Write everything down.
Who said what, when?
And then go.
Especially if you
have humans involved,
this is of paramount importance.
If this was
completely automated,
you would still have an
audit log because frequently,
something's going to happen
with some automated process.
You'll have bugs and
you need to go fix it.
So definitely
implement some type
of audit process for
this type of flow.
So how did we do?
We had six different games
and what we ran on TV
were the implied
probabilities for each one
of our predictions.
So we had an estimate.
We had some type
of continuous value
that came out of our
prediction models
and you can see down
at the bottom, where
we said second half total
three-point attempts combined,
the estimate was 24.
The result was 24.
So we nailed the estimate.
The ad that actually ran
was we will see at least 21
of these things at a
76.4% confidence level.
And the reason
why we did this is
that a television
ad, we couldn't
put things like confidence
intervals and plus/minus,
and stuff in the ads so we
did some work to basically,
take our estimate and convert
it into a probability.
So we nailed that one.
We nailed the combined
possessions one.
Total shot attempts-- we got
a little squirrelly there
because the Kansas-Villanova
game kind of got out of hand.
And that's the
whole fun of this.
It's like you think
you know what's
going to happen in the game
and then the game gets away
and sometimes, your
estimates are off.
If you want to learn
more about this process,
we built half of
a basketball court
in the bottom of Moscone South.
How many of you have
been down there yet?
Cool.
Feel free to come down.
I can get into any part
of this that you'd like.
And we also have a real-time
motion capture system set up
that you can see how good
or bad your jump shot is.
And it's a fun way to
get into data science
from a different angle,
just looking at scores like,
that's fun.
You can build live
TV ads, that's OK.
But seeing yourself in
real-time shooting a jumper,
that's pretty fun.
So with that said, I'll
stop, take some questions.
And I hope you have
a great rest of Next.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]